food and acne you've probably seen hundreds of
these sorts of videos and infographics giving you
all these foods you need to stop eating to cure
your acne is there any truth to this are all of
these foods actually giving you acne i'm michelle
of lab muffin beauty science chemistry phd and
cosmetic chemist and today we're going to be
talking about the science behind food and acne
i've had so many requests for this topic but
obviously diet talk can be very harmful so if
you're trying to avoid talk of diet and food
this is probably not going to be a good video
for you lots of dermatologists like my friend
dr anjali mahto have seen some of the damage
that diet-based skincare advice can cause she'll
be giving us some practical advice a bit later
but you've probably heard about the diet and
acne studies so we're going to talk about them
firstly there is zero doubt that things
you eat can potentially impact your skin
we get basically every chemical our body needs
from food apart from like oxygen and skin is part
of our bodies but a lot happens in between putting
food in your mouth and substances from that food
affecting your skin your digestive system breaks
down the food into its individual chemicals some
of that gets absorbed into your blood your liver
filters the chemicals and transforms some of them
and a whole bunch get yeeted out of your body and
then some of the substances that end up in your
blood get taken up into your skin which is about
as far from your blood as your body parts can get
or they might influence one thing in a very
long pathway that ends up affecting your skin
and there are a lot of other things
that can impact steps in this process
stress sleep hormones genetics the
skin care products you're using
gut bacteria medications and we know there
are tons of other things that affect acne
acne is a very complex condition so it's very
possible that everything else has a much larger
impact that you can't overcome just with tweaking
your diet so "you are what you eat" is technically
true but it isn't as straightforward as it
sounds it is incredibly tricky to work out
how specific foods in someone's diet might
eventually impact that specific person's skin
so science to the rescue let's do some
controlled experiments and see what happens
but it turns out that studying how diet impacts
someone's skin is just straight up annoying in
a scientific experiment we ideally want to
change one thing at a time for a proper test
that way you can be somewhat confident that the
thing you change caused the effect that you saw
so let's say we wanted to work out if chocolate
caused acne here would be an example of a perfect
study we would get a good mix of people probably
a few thousand to make sure that any effect we
saw wasn't just a fluke and we make them eat
and do everything the same except you would
give half of them chocolate and that way you can
compare what happens with and without chocolate
you'd also want to make sure that no one knows
whether or not they're eating chocolate and
this is because of expectation bias if
someone knew they were eating chocolate
and they expected that to give them
more pimples maybe they would subtly
change their other habits or maybe they'd
be stressed about it and that could affect
the outcome same with whoever's assessing
people's skin and counting people's pimples
maybe if they expected that people eating
chocolate would get more pimples they might
change how they would count a borderline bump
whether or not that would count as a pimple
the two groups would be using the exact
same skin care products have the exact
same diet so the same foods from the
same brands apart from the chocolate
they'd eat food at the same time they would
drink the same amount and types of alcohol
they wouldn't be allowed to smoke they would sleep
the same amount they would have the same amount
of stress and the same exposure to things like
sun and pollution you'd want to keep the people
in specialized accommodation so they couldn't
like sneak out and get secret midnight snacks
you'd also want to run the study for a good
amount of time because hormones and stress
you want that to be enough cycles that
you could get a good idea of whether
it's the chocolate or the stress or the hormones
causing any acne so probably at least six months
anyway it turns out you're not allowed to
jail people for six months for science even
if you're paying them and it turns out you have
to pay them a lot to convince people to let you
control every aspect of their lives so this
perfect setup never happens nutrition studies
have to make a lot of compromises so it's
a lot harder to be confident in the results
and because the studies aren't really controlling
all of the variables a lot of other things can
affect the results so unsurprisingly a lot
of these studies have contradictory results
so keeping in mind what our perfect
setup looks like let's have a look
at the two types of studies on
food and acne that we actually get
the first type are interventional studies where
they change people's diets and see what happens
this sounds a bit like our ideal situation except
these studies usually have less than 100 people
often a lot less we're talking an average of 30
something people in the trial that means 10 to
20 people in each group for example 17 people
getting chocolate and 17 not that is not a lot
of people it's really difficult to be confident
there wasn't some sort of fluke involved it's
quite possible that two people in the chocolate
group just happen to have honking big pimples that
week for some other reason like it's exam week or
it's a particular point in their menstrual cycle
another issue with these studies is that
they usually don't tightly control what
the participants eat for the chocolate studies
usually they give people a specific type and
amount of chocolate to eat but they don't
tell them what else they should be eating
so maybe having the chocolate meant they didn't
feel like eating as much fruit or ice cream
and it's actually the lack of fruit or
ice cream that's causing more pimples
a lot of these studies are also
on very specific groups of people
for example there are a lot of studies
where all of the participants are male
20 something college students in the us most
studies purposely use men because these studies
tend not to go for very long because it's a lot
cheaper that way usually they're four weeks or
less and with women there's the menstrual cycle
and this has a massive effect on acne the college
students part is because it's very easy to
bribe college students into doing a study
so this very limited group of people studied
means that it's difficult to see whether the
results would also apply to a woman in her
mid-30s like me or a teenage girl or a male
college student in japan we know that genetics
can have a really big role in how people process
food for example lactose intolerance
varies across ethnicity and by country
so generalizing these studies which
happens all of the time on social media
is a big problem you'll see the results
of these studies turn into part of a cute
infographic or three seconds in a tiktok video
but it's missing all of this extra context
three out of the four small studies on
chocolate published in the last 11 years
were done on just male college students and there
just aren't a lot of interventional studies done
on food and acne a 2021 review looked at all of
the studies in the last 11 years and they found
11 interventional studies that's 11
studies not just on chocolate and acne but
11 interventional studies on any
dietary change and acne since 2009
like i said good dietary studies are expensive
and complicated to run even though these are
still very far from that ideal situation and even
with all of these compromises they're still rare
there is another type of study as well that
adds to what we know about food and acne
observational studies these look at what people
are already doing and try to find patterns so for
example do people who eat more of a certain type
of food tend to have more acne there are more of
these studies because they're less of a pain to
run and they tend to have more participants and
more diverse participants but they have a lot of
other issues because the people are just going
about their everyday lives as the scientists
record what they eat and how their skin's going
that means that firstly there is a massive amount
of variation in what people are eating and doing
during the study there are a lot of little things
that could be impacting the results that won't be
recorded in the study secondly there's a big
issue with recording what people ate and what
happened to their skin in observational studies
participants usually have to tell the scientists
what they ate now if you know you have to
record your food it might change what you
eat and you might self-edit your food diary a bit
and if you've ever had to record your food intake
for whatever reason you'll know how hard it is to
record every single thing you eat and if you go to
a restaurant or get takeaway it is impossible to
work out how much of each ingredient you're eating
i recently had some random food allergies that i
haven't quite figured out yet and the number of
times i've told myself i'll write it down later
and then just straight up forgot is ridiculous
and a lot of the time the studies don't get people
to record their food they get them to fill out a
survey afterwards the problem here is that if
it's already hard to remember what you ate today
it is really really hard to remember
what you ate over the last two weeks
some of these food and acne studies got
people to remember what they ate years ago
the most highly cited study on dairy and acne
got their data by asking women in their 30s
and 40s what they ate when they were teenagers
and so all of these issues make it harder to
draw strong conclusions about what food caused
what effect with these observational studies
let's take a look at a recent
observational study as an example
scientists got 24 and a half thousand
people in france to track what they ate
over three days at the start middle and end of
a year the people were also asked whether or
not they had acne and the scientists found
that there was a statistically significant
association between current acne and eating
fatty and sugary foods sugary drinks and milk
so at face value it seems like this study
is saying that more sugar leads to more acne
but if we take a closer look we have lots of
people which is really good the study used
surveys for recording food which has the usual
issues with imperfect recall and self-editing
there's also the fact that most people
don't eat the same thing consistently
over a week let alone a year so these three day
snapshots might not reflect their usual diet
and then there's also that other data point the
acne out of the people who said they had acne
44% diagnose themselves only 37% were diagnosed
by dermatologists and even dermatologists get
it wrong so it's very possible that a lot
of these people didn't actually have acne
it could be something that looks
similar like folliculitis or rosacea
on top of this there are a lot of other
factors that could be messing up the results
three quarters of the people were female which
means there are lots of hormonal factors that
could skew the results for example there's pcos
which affects somewhere around 10% of women of
reproductive age and this is strongly linked to
acne there's also hormonal contraceptives which
can increase or decrease acne and roughly half of
the women in france use hormonal contraceptives
eating more sugary foods could also lead
to people eating less of other things like
vegetables and fruit and it might be the
fact that they're having less of these
things that could be leading to more acne
and not the sugary food itself eating more
sugar could also be a reflection of something
else that's the actual root cause of the acne
people who eat less sugar might also be more
health conscious in the rest of their lives
so for example they might have a closer
relationship with their doctor they might
exercise more they might have a less stressful
lifestyle correlation isn't necessarily causation
the association that the scientists found
between acne and these fatty and sugary foods
sugary drinks and milk was also quite weak
which means it's difficult to say whether
there would still be this association if
we took out some of these extra factors
so with all of this background you can hopefully
appreciate how hard it is to confidently say much
about links between food and acne and that's
why dermatology organizations are so careful
in their recommendations about changing your
diet to manage your acne the strongest links
that we have with this rather flawed evidence
are pretty weak associations which means it's
hard to say that eating these foods actually
cause the acne and that stopping these foods
will also stop acne but these are the
two things we have the most evidence for
firstly high glycemic index and glycemic
load diets these have lots of refined
sugar and carbohydrates that absorb quickly
into your bloodstream and they seem to be
the strongest link there is between diet and
acne it's still a weak link out of the three
interventional studies on low gi gl diets
and acne two of them found a relationship
but one of them found no significant
difference in acne with high and low gi
the second thing is dairy high intake of dairy
products seems to be associated with acne
this is a pretty confusing one because dairy is
a broad category and different studies define it
in different ways it seems like low fat and skim
milk are more strongly linked to acne than full
fat dairy yogurt and cheese don't seem to be
linked but whey protein does seem to be linked
with both high gi gl diets and dairy the proposed
ways that they could be leading to acne are pretty
similar both of them can increase the levels
of igf-1 and insulin in blood higher igf-1 can
increase androgen hormones specifically the male
hormones testosterone and dht these can increase
the production of sebum which is the natural oil
in your skin that can clog pores and increased
sebum is one of the contributors to acne higher
igf-1 can also lead to overgrowth of keratinocyte
cells in your skin which means you have more stuff
in your skin that can lead to clogged pores both
of these diets could also lead to inflammation
which is another one of the contributors to acne
unfortunately all of this extra context doesn't
really make for a great viral tiktok video
so how can we use this information? the science on
the link between food and acne is really not that
solid which isn't that different from a lot of
things in skincare there are a lot of grey areas
but the difference between skin care and food
is that adding or removing a skincare product
generally isn't a big deal changing your
diet is a much bigger deal especially
when it comes to the two types of
food we have the most evidence for
dietary changes can affect a lot more than just
your skin high gi foods and dairy are lots of
common foods so being very black and white and
restricting yourself to a fraction of the foods
you used to eat can easily lead to nutritional
deficiencies and a wildly unbalanced diet
and more importantly it can have a massive impact
on your mental health as well in particular with
disordered eating for example you've probably
heard of orthorexia which is essentially
an unhealthy obsession with eating the
correct foods one of the first published
case studies on orthorexia was a woman whose
disordered eating started when she started
cutting out fat from her diet to control her
acne and there are lots of examples in the
literature and around the internet where people
who changed their diets to try to kill their acne
ended up triggering an eating disorder or making
one worse it's not uncommon on skincare forums
to see people talking about what foods they
can't eat or how hard it is to avoid these
foods how they're avoiding going out with
their friends to control their temptation
how much guilt they're feeling when they
eat one piece of the so-called wrong food
so with all of this in mind all the issues
with the evidence and the potential dangers
you want to be very cautious when messing
around with your diet to try to clear your skin
the evidence is not robust
enough at this moment in time
to recommend dietary changes
alone for the management of acne
the official recommendation is if you notice
a food that might be making your acne worse
try not eating it for a short
time and see what happens
but if you do want to change your
diet to see if it impacts your skin
here are three tips from dr anjali mahto
tip number one be careful with bad
swaps that might make things worse
there are a small select group of people that may
be sensitive to dairy so if you do want to cut
dairy out of your diet and you want to switch to a
plant-based alternative maybe rather than jumping
from dairy to oat milk which is a common swap that
i see people making think about unsweetened soy or
almond milk instead now the reason for that is oat
milk has actually got a very high glycemic index
tip number two if you drink whey protein shakes
see if you can use a different protein source
i think that's one situation where people may
benefit again from switching to a plant-based
protein instead particularly because the amount
of cow's milk protein that you effectively get
in a whey protein supplement is actually quite
significantly high we're not talking about a
little splash in your coffee or a little
bit in your porridge and the third tip
think about maybe bringing in an expert
if you are genuinely thinking of removing
things from your diet you should really do it
in conjunction with a professional dietitian
if you start removing lots
of things you may end up with
essentially a diet that is missing a lot
of important nutrients that you might need
for your overall general health which is
obviously a situation that we want to avoid
and be really careful when
you're taking and spreading
simplified diet device there
can be very real harms involved
so i see a lot of patients that will cut out huge
food groups and usually it is dairy gluten and
sugar and if you look hard enough if you cut those
three things out according to the internet you can
fix every skin condition going and it gets to the
point where their skin's not getting any better
they're getting really anxious about the foods
that they can and can't eat and what ends up then
happening is people find themselves in a situation
where their diet becomes more and more restrictive
there is more anxiety around food and almost
the development of disordered eating patterns
because you become so paranoid that anything
that you might eat might trigger your acne
so if changing your diet isn't a great way to
try to fix your acne what might be a better idea
i think if you are going to try and manage your
acne at home before you seek professional help
i think actually looking at your skin
care routine is a far better starting
point than starting to cut things out of your diet
now if you have changed your skincare
up you've been doing it for a good four
to six weeks but you're still finding
that your acne is not getting any better
or it's getting worse or it's becoming more
extensive so it's not just affecting the face but
it's extending onto the neck the back the chest
the shoulders if it's starting to scar or leave
permanent markings and about 20 of people who
have acne will get permanent scarring or if it's
starting to affect your mental health you know
it's affecting your day-to-day and your confidence
all of those then are signs that you
should then move on to professional help
you've done what you can at home
and you've given that a good bash
and unfortunately this makes
for an even worse tiktok video
if you like this video give it a thumbs
up subscribe and click the nerdification
bell for more videos like this probably with
less dancing thank you so much to dr anjali
mato for helping me out on this video i've
linked the full interview in the description
her insights are always really
level-headed her instagram is
absolutely fantastic as well definitely one of my
top recommendations for dermatologists to follow